okay so now you're sure that everything
is okay
you know down there you're perfectly
healthy
that man has the largest penis i have
ever seen
i actually don't even know if you asked
mops forgot to look
i was distracted by the largest penis
i have ever seen ben come meet jerry's
wife
gail happy
holidays chris so good to see you i have
someone i'd like you to meet
i'm gayle gergich
gail your gail jerry's beautiful wife
who looks like that gail i hope you're
not in
any way uncomfortable that i'm here
since i dated your daughter oh
not at all you're welcome here at any
time
oops there's a little hair on your
shoulder
well look who's a silver fox
we'll look at that i'm sorry you're
okay you don't feel like your body's in
decay or death is inevitable
my my somebody's being a gloomy goose
yeah relax gloomy goose
welcome everybody to another gergich
christmas
now sadly one of our three beautiful
angels melo scent couldn't be here
tonight but
our other two beauties miriam and gladys
are going to help gail and me
play a little tune
here we go a caroling among the leaves
so green
here we come a wandering so fair to be
seen love and joy come to you
[Music]
so gail and jerry i thought about it a
lot there's no logical explanation
it is so wonderful to be part of such a
special day okay remember
under no circumstances can leslie know
about what's going on
she has to make that face do you
understand well i don't fully but my
lips are sealed
i asked for larry's help because he has
the most successful marriage of anyone i
know
to a gorgeous woman which honestly is
still a mystery to me like was it a
hypnosis accident
or something where they put gail under
and made her fall in love with larry
and never said the magic word to snap
her out of it like if i say
nutmeg will she wake up and start
screaming
wait while you were at jerry's did you
happen to get any information about his
history with gail like was she a russian
spy
and the kgb forced her to marry jerry as
a cover
you know it's a mystery ben let it go
yeah i can't it keeps me awake at night
hey maybe gail has one of those oliver
sex brain disorder
thingies like does she think jerry is a
friendly hat
i think you sold it eggs bacon
and toast eggs bacon and toast
why don't you start your day the darkest
way with
[Applause]
why don't you start your day the girl
gets way
with eggs burgers toast
i'm very good we sing that every morning
but it's an
extra treat because you're here to sing
it with us thanks
guys um jerry i wanted your last day at
work to be special and i feel like i let
you down
so i made you this scrapbook with nearly
four
amazing pages jam-packed with memories
of your time in the government oh my god
oh honey you look great in every one of
these
you are still the most handsome man
in the world to me ugh mom
come on yeah geez mom we're eating i
know
it doesn't make any sense leslie
that is really sweet of you but you
don't have to worry about me
i'm great here i want to show you
something
you almost dropped that clumsy
[Applause]
where am i i i know i didn't achieve all
my work goals but
leslie i don't care because for me the
best part about working at the parks
department was that i got to be home
every night
with my family at five o'clock and to me
that's what mattered most
well it's the best that's how jerry
thank you for sharing this with me i
you have a wonderful life mm-hmm oh here
they are
the hawk machine is here
i'm having some serious deja vu how many
times have you lost your wedding ring
too many times to count and it causes
real trouble with gail
and any time i lose my ring she turns
into a real grumpy goose
is that so oh yeah she'll say you know
gary you'd lose your head if it wasn't
screwed on tight
then she makes me go for the fresh
oranges for the morning oj probably
gonna get an earful when i get home
tonight
gail might even call me the b word
bozo i thought i'd bring over some fresh
oranges for you and gail
okay well that is just so kind donna
thank you
you're one of a kind gary oh and i just
want to thank you for taking me down
memory lane
your big b word buddy
gary gergich how would you like to be
the next mayor of pawnee indiana
what the hell is all this about you'll
see
well i gotta say there was a heck of a
lot of fun
oh my god what on earth
i pray for someone happy inauguration
day buddy
oh jeez leslie thank
oh
[Music]
the passing of our beloved mayor
gunderson
marks the end of an era but we are about
to begin
a new chapter in pawnee's history ladies
and gentlemen
the new mayor of the great city of
pawnee indiana
gary gergich i just want to say
[Applause]
i'm flying
jim how the heck are you yeah look i
hate to bother you but i'm here with my
two best friends
leslie knope and tom haverford and we
need the first floor maintenance room
open
um okay great and best to louise and the
girls
okay bye-bye you guys are all set thank
you mayor gergich you really saved our
butts
i am so happy that you get to be mayor
are you enjoying yourself
oh are you kidding me leslie i know that
this is purely ceremonial and
it'll be over in just a couple of weeks
but i just don't know how my life could
get any better than this
in eternal events both shocking and
unexpected
interim mayor gary gergich was
officially elected today
thanks to a massive write-in campaign
mayor gergich uh what are your plans for
your first actual term oh geez
uh you know what i have no idea perd
this is so
crazy i just hope i do a good job and i
promise i'm gonna try my best
and faithfully serve the people of
pawnee indiana
as president of city council i
councilwoman brandy max
star of more than 11 000 adult films in
the last two years
officially declare gary gergich mayor of
pawnee indiana for the fourth time
thank you pawnee okay great
gary gergich you are now mayor again for
the tenth time
proving conclusively that in these
corporate states of america
it's the entrenched powers who hold all
the cards
thank you councilman morris thank you
pawnee
happy birthday my sweet sweet husband
we all love you so much i have had
the perfect life i have had the perfect
marriage
the perfect children and the perfect
grandchildren
and great grandchildren
and i just want you to know how much i
love you
okay come on everybody say gergich
[Applause]
mayor gary gergich died peacefully in
his sleep
on his 100th birthday holding the hand
of his beloved wife
gail man gail looks amazing
yeah yeah i know he will now be given
the indiana
notary society's highest honor the 21
stamp salute
rest in peace friend they
spelled his name wrong on the tombstone
[Music]
close enough huh who's gary
oh i think that's supposed to be me
ha-ha that's your new name
gary gary gary gary
gary gary
is my real name yes after 30 years my
co-workers are finally going to call me
by my real
name oh boy i'm blessed
you